Forschungsteams weltweit sind dabei, unsere
Ernährung upzudaten.
Heißt also konkret: Ersatzstoffe für Zucker
und Fett, lange Haltbarkeit ohne Chemie und
Fleisch aus dem Labor.
Was sind also die neuesten Trends aus den
Laboren der Lebensmitteltechnologie und sind
sie wirklich gesünder und nachhaltiger?
Das alles und noch viel mehr - jetzt bei Clixoom
Science & Fiction; herzlich willkommen!
Und am Ende des Videos habe ich noch ein Goodie
für euch.
Ein kostenloses Exepmlar der Zeitschrift Technology
Review.
Sehr cool.
In Zusammenarbeit mit der Redaktion ist dieses
Video entstanden.
Eine große Umfrage von Anfang des Jahres
zeigt, dass wir Deutschen durchaus bereit
sind, uns gesünder zu ernähren.
Mehr als die Hälfte der Befragten sprach
sich für verbindliche Höchstwerte von Salz,
Zucker und Fett aus.
Kann hier die Lebensmitteltechnologie helfen?
Wir haben für Euch die vier spannendsten
Aspekte zusammengestellt:
1.
Süße ohne Zucker
Mittlerweile ist Zucker sogar noch unbeliebter
als Fett.
Kein Wunder, dass die Liste der Ersatzstoffe
lang ist: Lactit, Maltit, Isomalt, Mannit,
Sorbit sind oft zwar genauso süß wie Zucker,
haben aber viele Kalorien.
Süßstoffe wie Aspartam haben zwar keine
Kalorien, machen auf Dauer aber trotzdem dick.
Teilweise wirken sie auch abführend.
Ein Nachteil von Stevia ist der bittere Nachgeschmack.
Forschungsteams weltweit haben also eine große
Aufgabe: Finde eine Substanz, die so süßt
wie Zucker, aber keine der gerade genannten
Nachteile mit sich bringt.
Ein Forschungsteam des Massachusetts Institute
of Technology (MIT) hat sich deswegen zur
Aufgabe gemacht, dem Stevia-Süßstoff den
bitteren Beigeschmack zu nehmen.
Dazu haben sie entsprechende Pflanzengene
in Bakterien eingebaut, sodass diese die leckeren
Stevia-Bestandteile produzieren - das bittere
Bei-Produkt Steviosid dagegen nicht.
Die Substanz gilt nach ersten Prüfungen als
gesundheitlich unbedenklich.
Die deutsche Brain AG setzt auf die Suche
in Pflanzen-Naturstoff-Datenbanken und hat
bereits 60 Kandidaten identifiziert, die mindestens
das 50-fache der Zuckersüßkraft aufweisen.
Jetzt wird geprüft, welche Stoffe für welche
Lebensmittel am besten geeignet sind.
Fest steht jedenfalls: Zucker in Gerichten
machen diese nicht nur süßer, sondern kaschieren
auch Bitterstoffe.
Und so lautet die grundlegende Frage: Wie
entsteht eigentlich der Geschmackseindruck?
Gezuckerte Erdbeeren schmecken intensiv nach
Früchten; Salz dagegen macht den gewünschten
Erdbeergeschmack kaputt.
Diese Mechanismen, nämlich, dass sich die
Geschmacksstoffe gegenseitig beeinflussen,
könnte man gezielt ausnutzen.
Der Zuckeranteil könnte durch den Einsatz
von Vanille-Noten oder Auszügen der Tonkabohne
reduziert werden.
Denn diese intensivieren das Empfinden von
Süße.
Dazu der Forscher Christian Zacherl: „Kennt
man solche Zusammenhänge, lässt sich der
Zuckergehalt um bis zu 20 Prozent und der
Salzgehalt sogar um 20 bis 30 Prozent senken”.
Aber auch die Verteilung des Zuckers spielt
eine wichtige Rolle.
Wenn er auf der Produkt-Oberfläche aufgetragen
ist, schmeckt es gleich süßer als wenn der
Zucker gleichmäßig eingearbeitet ist.
Doch die Reduktion von Zucker hat auch seine
Nachteile: beispielsweise eine kürzere Haltbarkeit,
denn Zucker entzieht Bakterien das Wasser
und hemmt so ihr Wachstum.
Der Lebensmittelkonzern Nestlè dagegen versucht,
den Zucker neu zu erfinden - und zwar ohne
Kalorien.
Es hat poröse Zuckerpartikel entwickelt,
die sich - genau wie Zuckerwatte - schnell
auf der Zunge auflösen.
So ließe sich der Zuckergehalt von Süßwaren
um bis zu 40 Prozent reduzieren.
Und das, ohne dass der Geschmack darunter
leide.
Noch dieses Jahr sollen die ersten Produkte
auf den Markt kommen.
2) Geschmack ohne Fett
Lange Zeit wurden Fette regelrecht verteufelt.
Heute dagegen gehen viele Experten davon aus,
dass Zucker weitaus schädlicher ist.
Dennoch: Zu viel Fett und vor allem zu viele
gesättigte Fettsäuren gelten noch immer
als ungesund.
Transfette, die bei der Verarbeitung von Sojaöl
entstehen, sind in den USA seit 2015 sogar
verboten.
Fettreduzierte Produkte sollen das Übel mindern;
sie werden aber von Vielen auch als nicht
so lecker empfunden.
Kein Wunder, denn Fett ist Geschmacksträger
Nummer 1: Fettliebende Substanzen lösen sich
in ihm - und ihr Geschmack dadurch verstärkt.
Als Ausweg wird dann oft Zucker eingesetzt,
um den fehlenden Geschmack zu kompensieren.
Das US-Unternehmen “ Choco Finesse” hat
eine modifizierte Fettstruktur an den Start
gebracht, die denselben Geschmack liefert
- aber eben OHNE die lästigen Kalorien.
Die Idee ist schon einige Jahrzehnte alt und
ziemlich clever: Drei Fette und ein Molekül
Glycerin bilden zusammen die Struktur von
Fetten.
Durch den Einbau eines Abstandhalter-Moleküls
wird das modifizierte Fettmolekül aber nicht
abgebaut und verdaut, sondern direkt wieder
ausgeschieden.
Dieser Fettersatz wird Epogee genannt und
ist noch nicht in unabhängigen Studien untersucht
worden.
Auch Lupinenproteine könnten demnächst als
Fettersatz dienen - zwar auch mit Kaloren
ausgestattet, aber bei weitem nicht so viele
wie Fett selbst.
Die Proteinsuspension ist dickflüssig und
ähnelt Fettpartikeln in Bratwurst.
Sie könnte also den Geschmack von fettarmer
Wurst deutlich verbessern.
3) Fleisch ohne Tier
Ihr wisst es alle: Zunächst einmal sind da
die ethischen Aspekte, aber auch für die
Umwelt bedeutet die Massentierhaltung eine
riesige Katastrophe.
Denn um beispielsweise ein Mastschwein heranzuziehen,
braucht es fast eine Million Liter Trinkwasser.
Und zwar ganz allein, um sein Futter anzubauen.
Gefüttert wird es hauptsächlich mit Soja,
für dessen Anbau beispielsweise Regenwälder
in Brasilien weichen müssen.
Auch das Grundwasser wird durch die Massentierhaltung
verschmutzt, und zwar mit Nitrat.
Durch die Gülle werden die Böden überdüngt-
große Mengen an Stickstoff lagern sich im
Boden ab und sorgen dafür, dass verschiedene
Tier- und Pflanzenarten sterben.
Und zuletzt wird auch der Klimawandel durch
die Massentierhaltung gefördert.
“Wir wollen das für die Fleischindustrie
sein, was das Auto für die Pferdekutsche
war”, sagt Uma Valeti, der Chef des kalifornischen
Start Up-Unternehmens “Memphis Meats”.
Seine Produkte kommen nach eigenen Angaben
ohne Antibiotika, Schlachtungen und Hormone
aus.
Zudem sollen dabei rund 90 Prozent weniger
Treibhausgase entstehen.
Memphis Meats lässt Fleisch im Bioreaktor
wachsen.
Hier vereinen sich Muskelzellen zu Fleischstücken.
Investoren sind der Virgin-Gründer Richard
Branson und Microsoft-Gründer Bill Gates.
Die Herstellungskosten dieser Produkte sind
mit immer noch 4000 Dollar pro Pfund viel
zu hoch.
Doch die Verantwortlichen sind optimistisch,
den Preis in den nächsten drei Jahren so
zu senken, dass die Produkte es auf den Markt
schaffen.
Klar, auch dann werden es immer noch Luxusprodukte
sein und die ersten Abnehmer werden wohl Edelrestaurants
sein.
Aber spätestens in fünf Jahren soll es dann
auf dem Massenmarkt-Niveau angekommen sein.
Dazu der Geschäftsführer von “MosaMeat”,
Peter Verstrate:” Wir haben herausgefunden,
wie wir sowohl die Produktionsbedingungen
als auch die Nährstoffkosten verbessern können.
Das macht uns zuversichtlich, langfristig
so günstig wie ‚normales‘ Fleisch zu
werden, wahrscheinlich sogar noch günstiger”.
Sein Unternehmen nimmt als Nährmedium nicht
mehr das ethisch problematische fetale Kälberserum,
sondern das Blut ungeborener Kälber.
Auch Antibiotikum wollen die Hersteller nach
eigenen Angaben nicht mehr einsetzen.
Doch es gibt weitere Herausforderungen: Denn
bisher sind nur sehr dünne Zellschichten
bis zu einem Millimeter möglich - also alles
andere als ein dickes Steak.
Denn dann lassen sich die Zellen nicht mehr
ausreichend mit Nährstoffen versorgen.
Dennoch gehen Mikrobiologen davon aus, dass
dieses “Fleisch” durchaus gesünder sein
könnte.
Und wohl auch nachhaltiger als die konventionelle
Fleisch-Produktion - das sagt zumindest eine
Studie aus 2011, die einer Tonne Laborfleisch
einen günstigeren Umweltfußabdruck bescheinigt
als der selben Menge Tierfleisch.
Beim Energieverbrauch ist das ganze wohl nicht
mehr so ganz klar: Hier ist der Aufwand für
das Kulturfleisch wohl größer als beim herkömmlichen
Fleisch.
Das zumindest legt eine Studie aus dem Jahr
2015 nahe.
Dann kommt es letztendlich wohl noch auf den
Geschmack an, der die Verbraucher überzeugen
muss.
4.)
Haltbar ohne Chemie
Bislang sorgen chemische Substanzen in unseren
Nahrungsmitteln dafür, dass sich gefährliche
Pilze und Bakterien in ihnen vermehren.
Doch sie sollen langfristig durch gesundheitlich
unbedenkliche Konservierungsmittel ersetzt
werden.
Denn schon jetzt werfen wir Deutschen pro
Jahr 82 kg Lebensmittel weg.
Eine wirklich schlimme Zahl, für die wir
uns schämen sollten!
Das Deutsche Institut für Lebensmitteltechnik
schlägt das sogenannt “Cool Juice”-Verfahren
vor, bei dem die Membran der Keime mit pulsierenden
elektrischen Feldern durchlöchert wird.
Damit könnten Fruchtsäfte haltbar gemacht
werden - bis zu sechs Wochen lang.
Zudem würden Vitamine und Geschmack geschont.
Wenn das Verfahren beim Frittieren von Pommes
oder Chips eingesetzt wird, gibt es sogar
einen tollen Nebeneffekt: Die Produkte nehmen
bis zu 30 Prozent weniger Fett auf.
Aber auch Pflanzenextrakte können Nahrungsmittel
haltbar machen, beispielsweise Hopfenbestandteile.
Das steigere die Haltbarkeit von Fleischmarinaden
um 50 Prozent, so die Forschungsergebnisse.
Rosmarinextrakt wird übrigens bei Tiefkühlpizzen
schon als natürliches und schonendes Konservierungsmittel
eingesetzt.
Das Fraunhofer IVV baut gerade eine Datenbank
auf, um zu analysieren, wo genau die Geschmacksschwelle
für solche Naturstoffe liegt.
Vielen Dank an Technology Review!
In Zusammenarbeit mit der Redaktion dieser
ziemlich coolen Zeitschrift ist dieses Video
entstanden.
Und exklusiv für Clixoom-Zuschauer habe ich
jetzt ein Geschenk: Ihr bekommt nämlich eine
Ausgabe gratis, wenn ihr auf diesen Link klickt.
Das lohnt sich wirklich.
Und hier geht es weiter mit (dafür drauf
auch klicken) “Erschreckend: Wir essen Unmengen
Mikroplastik“ Bis dann, bleibt dran!